hello everyone and welcome to another
most impressive game from round seven of
the 2020 Tata Steel masters edition it's
early as a future versus Jeffress young
to younger twin members of the 2700 club
young is a bit older he's 19 whereas
Alvarez is still only 16 but two of them
played some really impressive chess so
without further ado let's check it out
as it's quite quite an intensive game
with efore by alla days at a five-night
of three Knight to c6 and the now Bishop
to b5 the rule opus is on the board
Knight of 6 we have the Berlin defense
and now d3 and we have Bishop to c5 the
newly called alpha 0 Berlin defence with
Bishop captures on c6 d captures and
castles by white with Knight to d7
defending the e5 pawn this way and now
c3 now preparing to push the d4 pawn all
the way with castles by young and
fallujah goes for d4 and here there was
one game it captures on d4 Nakamura
plated against time and in the
Grantchester
paris rapid event that game ended in a
draw but here we have brushed back to d6
adding another defender to the e5 pawn
Bishop to g5 now developing attacking
the Queen and now f6 pushing the bishop
back Russia page for end Queen to d8 now
the Queen can now perhaps even go to h5
to g6 and the world even f5 might be
possible in the future as now the the DF
1 is no longer pinned so rook to e1 and
now there is one game where b6 was
played on and plated in in the Bucharest
boots tournament against look 1 we ended
game ended in a draw but here we have
night to b6 and it is as of move 11 that
we have a completely new game which
again is very very interesting as it is
the the Berlin
so Bishop to g3 in countering blacks
dark square Bishop are also adding
another attacker to the e5 pawn and now
Bishop to g4 pinning one of the
attackers so Knight bTW - and now the
night is defended you might play h3 at
some points to recapture with the Knight
and King h8
I useful move as you don't want your
King on this diagonal and the Const
we having to calculate Queen to b3 so
Queen to c2 developing connecting rooks
and the now rook to d8 and h3 finally
so Bishop to h5 not interested in in
giving up the bishop air just yet and
now Knight to h4 as the Queen unpinned
so now of course you want to bring your
knight to the five and if black wants to
kick it away he will either have to
bring some pieces over or weaken the
King even further with g6 so ii capture
Sundy for now for the moment not
allowing night to land on f5 threatening
Bishop captures here so Capra's on d6
and now Shion plays a very very
important institution to a nice
in-between moved III before recapturing
here not allowing whites to capture the
pawn this way to to improve his center
so d3 Queen captures and only now fixing
his own pawn structure with C captures
on d6 we have f4 byali reza and now
there should be back to f7 we have
Knight d2 F 3 and now comes Bush back to
g8 saying that ok now you could bring
your Knight to f5 but for the moment
it's not it's not really gonna do
anything so what can you do here instead
of Bishop g8 you could try some other
ideas but for example you could try to
improve the position of this Knight but
for example if Knight to c4 b3 just
kicks it away so not really gaining any
new squares and if instead you try
Knight to d7 then you weaken the d6 pawn
Knight at five now comes a very happily
with a double attack on the pawn here
so instead like I said Bishop g8 and the
now comes Knight to d4 now Knight to f5
doesn't really pack all that much punch
because there's a there's this tricky
line Queen to f7 and now if you go after
the pawn now you get Queen to c7 with a
double attack on the night ie 5
characters captures and then out Knight
to c4 the bishop nicely defends it there
and next move you're just gonna capture
and win your phone back so it's it's not
a problem so instead of a razor goes
Knight to d4 now this Knight can come to
f5 as well
we have c5 Bishop to c4 seems you know
aesthetically pleasing but other than
that doesn't really do anything all that
much you're just gonna move the Queen
and that's just it
so c5 pushing the knight Knight d2 f5
and now Queen to d7 Queen to f7 is also
possible here with the same idea trying
to get white to capture here but here
what can just play Queen g3 put constant
pressure on g7 and then bring the rook
to d1 and go after the phone this way so
instead we have Queen to d7 by Sheung
defending the d6 pawn in the now b3
taking away the c4 and a four squares
from blacks pieces and now as always
allowed it d5 finally getting rid of the
backwards past
the backwards d6 pawn we have a five by
allah reza and now Bishop to e6 putting
pressure on the night here Knight back
to g3 and now you can even feel free to
pause the video here and figure out what
you would play here with black you know
it just as just as a an idea how
complicated the position is while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who found the move that I'm about to
show you congratulations as it's
definitely not an easy to find but an
even harder move to play in an over the
board game and that is G v g5 seems to
be weakening the King a bit too much but
after captures captures and the knight
moves Knight of three it's actually a
queen e7 defending it's actually a solid
position for black and this is what
seemingly should have been played but
okay now Schumann goes for f5 instead he
keeps the position closed and now Knight
back to f3 just hoping to get the night
or to this very nice g5 square we have
h6 not allowing it but again further
weakening now the knight could go back
night h4 to g6 but Holliday the first
goes B for the idea is that he wants to
remove the defender of the d4 square he
wants to get his knight there and here
the way you wanna defend c5 is Knight to
a4 this is how we want to do it but she
only decided that he wanted to play a
bit more actively so he went for
a temporary point sacrifice he played d4
and okay we have characters on c5 and
now D chapters on c3 is saying that if
if the queens are traded then the knight
can capture and there is no more threat
of Punk at first Knight
so after this D captures and c3 move we
have Queen captures on c3 so now you
wrap upon but Knights the d5 black now
gains a lot of activity Queen back to D
2 and now Queen to a for putting a lot
of pressure on the undie a for pawn here
and also with a double attack on the F
for pawn so here Alireza goes nice to e
2 defense DF for pawn and he says ok
it's not a problem you can win back your
pawn I'm just gonna have a much more
active play and also the Queen cover
covers all the squares that the knight
can use for some nasty discoveries so
it's not a problem at this relationship
between the rook and the Queen that does
not favor black all that much so
tonight's the B for now with a triple
attack on the pawn and also opening up a
discovery here Knight eat a d4 this was
all addresses plan all along
blocking this so we have Knight back to
c6 adding now a triple attacker to the
night just rook a to d1 giving back the
pawn but regaining the pressure but
should capture Sunday - and now Queen to
c3 unpinning
and continuing to play the game so what
can you do here well as white will
definitely start pushing the pawn here
the question is whether you want to
capture on d4 and then play rogue d5 or
play rogue d5 right away
Irish young decided for ruga d5 right
away point being that once the pawn
starts marching forward you can block
with the rook and then this rook will be
guarding the f5 pawn so this is exactly
what happens all erisa starts pushing
rook to e8 and now rook the d2 by all
Araiza again a very sneaky move
threatening rook to a-1 to win the
bishop here so you have to move it or
play what she um played here Queen to c4
offering a queen trade as the Queen and
c3 is undefended
so Queen captures on c4 Bishop captures
and now nightcaps origin hide captures
on c6 b captures and now again a very
sneaky move while it is a rook to d4
threatening to win the bishop and
inviting a trade here after Knight
captures the knight will also be
guarding e6 so it's not a problem and if
you grab the pond and rook c1 just wins
the material there is no way to to get
out of the threat here so Bishop to b3
by young and now rook to e3 again going
after the Bishop Bishop to a2 and now
before going rook to a3 which will come
with a double attack first isse evan
limit the movements of the rook as much
as possible
King g8 you wanna bring your King as
close as possible and now rook to a3
attacking the bishop and the a7 pawn so
here first
Shyam trades on d4 rook captures Knight
captures and now Bishop to b5 an
important move defends the c6 pawn but
you cannot defend everything you cannot
defend this this and this so first
Knight captures on f5 very important as
it again guards the pawn here and it
just eliminates a lot of blacks counter
play so if you ever want to get rid of
that night you're gonna have to weaken
your structure even further because if
you attack it with the with the bishop
dangerous Knight d4 comes with an attack
on the bishop and the point that doesn't
work so g6 you have to get rid of these
7 pawn Knight captures with check King
g7 and now Knight to g4 finally rook
captures on e7 but now Knight e3
attacking the bishop a white is hoping
to get Bishop captures here so he can
get a nice pass C pawn so Bishop to e4
and now King f2 we have looked d7 are
hoping to get rook to D to check in so
nice that c4 guarding the d2 square with
the knife rule b7 and now comes g4 with
Buster back to d5 and now again tonight
back to e3 hoping for Knight captures on
d5
we have rook tabby to with check King g3
and now rook the b3 this is a not an
easy move to play for black because
you're willingly trading rooks well sort
of offering a roof trade but rook to b7
guarding the pawn isn't isn't good
enough because of again characters
capture sand King f3 and it's just gonna
be very hard even though black is the
one with
- passed pawns it's it's not gonna be
easy for example rook c7 rook c3
defending now you can go d4 attacking
the rook rook c1 and now even a5 start
pushing this point but the white king is
just much more active a4 you're gonna
capture here you're up two points now so
it's not even not even close
so after this King G to remove we have
rook to be three by Shion and of course
ali reza are not interested in trading
because the a 7-point hangs with check
so rook captures with check King f6 and
now kink the f2 guarding rugby to check
we have kink to f1 and now the problem
is black cannot continue checking if you
continue checking rugby one check kingi
to Roby to check you're gonna go king d3
rugby three check King d2 and now after
finally Ruby to check you're gonna go
King to c1 and yes you do reach the H
bone however again you have the problem
of characters captures and just rook a
six check the pawns do not allow the
King to come any closer
King has to go back now g5 and yes you
do get the h3 pawn but now King be to
not allowing rook c3 to put rook behind
the past pawn and well after rook f3
you're just gonna block with check if
you go there than you you can also grab
this guy and if you go here then just c6
and it's of course a winning endgame for
white c7 c8 of course coming
so after King f1 Bishop to e4 Shion can
never allow Knight captures on d5 but
now comes Luke to d7 the rook can also
help out to wit with the checks so rook
to h2 going after the H point for now
but now rook to d4 forcing the bishop to
come to d5 so Bishop to f3
but now rook d6 check King g7 and now
comes the break through f5 finally so G
captures an F Knight captures with Czech
king of seven and now g5 so the h3 pawn
will be given away but it doesn't really
matter because if you capture it right
away
g6 check if you go here or here it's
just the rook to d8 mate so you have to
go King to e8 the g7 is coming the
there's no stopping this so it's really
just pointless king of seven route d8
again no stopping the pawn
so after g5 Bishop to h5 now preventing
g6 but rook the f6 check we have King to
g8 and now g6 there was no stopping this
rook that force on h3 you don't have
really a better move now Knights the e7
check by ali reza and now if you go King
g7 the problem is you you get rook f7
checking h6 rook h7 check King goes to
g5 and now g7 wins the game there is no
way to prevent queening other than
playing Bishop to f7 but then just roof
captures on h3 and it's game over
so after 97 kink the h8 was played by
shunk and now feel free to pause the
video and try to find it the winning
move for white while I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on paying
attention as it's basically just forcing
black into the line we just shown rook F
8 check this is what all it has a plate
King g7 and now we go into the line that
we just discussed rook f7 sure king - if
King a trade and rook h7 is made the
night covers g8 so after Luke f7 check
King h6 rook checks king g5 and now g7
and it was in this position that
Geoffrey Xian resigned the game and yet
another victory for our eyes of Fallujah
in this tournament so from 7 games 4
wins and all 4 with the white pieces
which is very interesting because the
next player here si will have white
against is Magnus Carlsen so will be
very interesting
well I'll erase a continue here's a
winning streak with the white pieces or
will Magnus continue his undefeated
streak for who knows how many games now
maybe even 115 until then and again it's
the same line so yeah there's no way is
to stop the point you have to go into
this but then just rope captures and
it's just pointless so yeah that's what
I wanted to mention here are the
standings after seven rounds there we
have it oh there is a fuchsia in Seoul
lead with five out of seven incredible
stuff and there you can see his his
performance rating is almost 29,000 2920
889 followed by Wesley so and Jordan one
forest with four and a half then with
three and a half points we have a lot of
people youngsters will do that for being
a karana Magnus Carlsen still do
the diri viswanathan anand daniel dubov
initially in the Ladislav Artemyev with
three points Jeffrey Xian with two and a
half
Nikita fatigue of and you young [ __ ] and
with one and a half points still in last
place
Vladislav Kovalev not not able to catch
a break just yet and also with this wind
underlie breathing's Alireza breaks
through into the top twenty chess
players in the world there you have it
in number nineteen there you have it all
it has a Fallujah who surpassed under
eighteen artemiev ye with you go from
Nakamura top all of and now okay to
catch up the Carrick in Kramnik and the
rest of them he needs quite a few more
wins but okay top twenty
he definitely joins joins the elite so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
a next game a Larissa has a black
against one forest also one of the well
not the leaders but him and Wesley are
trying to catch up to a leaders and now
and then in round nine white against
Magnus that's gonna be that's gonna be a
crazy game so once again I would like to
thank Ken Thompson
Christopher Gordon Frank combs a
Salvatore John brunette and the
Christelle day for a contributor to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos serum thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Tata
Steel chess tournament the coverage of
the women's butchers championship
checking up on your suggestions and of
course whatever else happens in the
chess world so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your Saturday